[Music]
English lessons hello today's mini
English lesson is false friend
what is the false friend anyway fast
friends are words in different languages
that look today we're going to look at
three common false friends in English
and in French the first one is actually
and written in English actually is a
synonym for really or in fact for
example so what actually happened in
French actually means present time now
and better translated to currently you
still with me
in the second place we have some petite
and sympathetic in English someone who
is sympathetic is someone who cares
about somebody else's feelings and who
shows that they care for example I am
sympathetic to the Liverpool fans did
not win the Premier League when in
French somebody just means nice in
English finally in the third place one
of the most common mistakes with false
friends is between sensible and saucy
sensible is
for careful rational somebody who
doesn't take rash decisions where some
seed means somebody who is sensitive in
English so you see it's important to
check the words in the dictionary before
you use them sometimes they're
transparent sometimes they play tricks
on you well I hope you've enjoyed this
mini English lesson
[Music]